dazu gebracht
durch alle projekte ja warum alter
direkt
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich mir
überlegt es gibt vier rezepte mit
blätterteig also wirklich schnelle
rezepte die könnt ihr dann entweder zu
silvester machen oder auch zu anderen
partys und veranstaltungen also das
ganze jahr über ich habe mir das macht
zwei süße und zwei herzhafte rezepte ich
starte direkt mit einem süßen rezept es
gibt nämlich muscheln und dafür brauchen
wir natürlich blätterteig wie jetzt in
jedem dieser vier rezepte ich nehme
tiefgekühlt in welcher zeit kommt dann
in so rechtecken ihr könnt aber auch
diesen eingerollten aus dem kühlregal
nehmen ich muss sagen das sind so sachen
die habe ich immer zu hause ein paar
tiefkühlregal und da machen wir es
einfach folgendes wir bestreichen unsere
platten immer mit etwas butter und
überlappen sie dann ich muss sagen dass
mir diese idee relativ spontan
eingefallen dass dieses video zu machen
ist mir überlege ich gerade ob ich diese
schmecken so groß lassen sind oder ich
mach mal auf die gefahr hin dass es
vielleicht zu klein wird aber wir
probieren zum aus werde ich sie jetzt
hier nochmal
halbieren und dann hab ich mir hier
butter zerlassen
wenn ich mir hier nochmal pinsel und
dann einfach immer wieder mit pinseln
und überlappen
[Musik]
ich habe den blätterteig jetzt noch mal
so ein bisschen flacher gerollt einmal
auch so hoch kam damit aber auch so
seitlich mal ein bisschen in die breite
rollen und jetzt wird das ganze
aufgerollt so richtig schön engen und
dann schneide ich mir scheiben runter
die müssen jetzt auch nicht so dick sein
im blätterteig geht er im ofen auch noch
mal richtig auf und so erhalten wir dann
quasi gleich unsere muschel form das
werdet ihr gleich nach dem backen dann
auch nochmal genauer sehen so und vorne
dieses unschöne stück das schneide ich
jetzt so ganz grob weg
zack und dann ich würde sagen das ist so
ein halber zentimeter
einfach die scheiben runter schneiden
und dann kann man das gleich das zeige
ich euch hier direkt man kann man das
gleich noch mit den fingern so ein
bisschen flach andrücken und jetzt könnt
ihr euch überlegen was da für eine
füllung rein kommt also das ist halt
eine marmelade von mir die hit mit
sparsamen eingedeckt und die hat nur
noch dattel süße ihr könnt aber
alles was er möchte ich wollte euch nur
mal gezeigt haben es gibt sich bald im
shop und dann nehme ich mir einfach so
ein bisschen was auch nicht zu viel das
nicht ausläuft gibt das in die mitte und
verschließt das dann
[Musik]
eigentlich wollte ich ja mein jetzt
trennen aber manchmal passiert zeigt das
komplette einer reinrutscht und daher
könnt ihr euch einfach so eine leere
plastikflasche nehmen kurz an drücken
und dann wieder loslassen und dann
flüchtet quasi hier rein dann könnte das
hier wieder entfernt und sollte sauber
getrennt ist ich gebe hier noch ein
bisschen milch mit dazu das braucht
übrigens jetzt dass das ganze video über
na also wenn es dann quasi aufgebraucht
ist könnt ihr euch noch ein eigelb
schlagen und mit er nicht verdienen das
ganze schön verqueren das sorgt jetzt
nicht für geschmack oder so sondern
einfach nur für die schöne goldbraune
farbe dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt einfach
den pinsel von vorhin die wasche ich
jetzt auch nicht aus ist ja ein roter
dran und dann einfach pinseln bei 190
grad ober und unterhitze in den
vorgeheizten backofen richtig dass der
vorgeheizt ist bis sie wirklich gold
frauen sind und dann würde ich sagen
machen wir auch schon direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten rezept
[Musik]
so ist nächste süße rezept das sind
einfach schoko blätterteig ringel die
gehen so schnell und einfach ich nehme
hier meine schokocreme ihr könnt einfach
eure lieblings creme nehmen eure
lieblings krems hat wichtig ist klar
sodann verstreiche ich einfach hier die
leckere haben man hätte den latschen
gelaufen
und da kommt dann gleich hey ich das
noch ja ich kann aber auch gerne mit dir
so nett bin ich ganz deutlich dass noch
auf dem pausenhof mal diese schüler die
nie was zu essen dabei hatten noch mal
gefragt ist so dass noch also einfach
drüber liegen und dann schneiden wie so
dünne streifen beim tiefkühl blätterteig
müsste einfach nur darauf achten dass er
so ein bisschen an getaucht ist und
jetzt einfach nur noch zwiebeln und
quasi zu kriegel form ab aufs backblech
und dann noch mal mit der schule
streichen ich bin jetzt fertig mit
meinem schoko kringeln ich habe auch
übrigens zwei noch mal so ganz dünn
geformt dafür einfach nochmal
durchschneiden eigentlich ist es echt
persönliche präferenz ich muss sagen mir
gefallen sie so dick ein bisschen besser
und ich könnte sie jetzt aber auch nicht
gleichzeitig backen bzw ich müsste die
dann auf jeden fall vorher raus holen
weil je weniger blätterteig umso
schneller werden sie natürlich goldbraun
bei der backzeit ich schreibe die
genauen zeiten euch immerhin ich vermute
sind auch 20 minuten wie bei den
muscheln aber wie gesagt ich schreibe
euch lieber hin dann geht ihr auf nummer
sicher ich werde jetzt goldbraun backen
und dann gehen wir auch schon direkt
über zum herzhaften rezept
[Musik]
für das nächste rezept das erste
herzhaft in diesem video habe ich hier
ganz normalen frischkäse und den werden
wir jetzt auch finden ich nehme
knoblauch da kommen gleich noch passte
mal dazu das ist quasi türkischer rinder
schinken und
er könnte aber auch variieren je nachdem
was ihr mögt dann gebe ich dann nur noch
salz pfeffer und italienische kräuter
mit rein und wir brauchen aber noch was
zur bindung da könnt ihr entweder
speisestärke nehmen oder er nimmt ein
ich mache das mit dem eisstock dann
nämlich noch schön im ofen und dann wird
das einfach nur noch verrührt
[Musik]
so die frisch das ist jetzt fertig wir
nehmen uns jetzt einen muffin blech am
besten noch einmal vorher einsprüche
nehme einfach meine olivenöl spray ihr
könnt aber auch einfach das was wir
gerade hat so damit dass auch später
nämlich gut raus bekommen und jetzt
nehmen wir uns unseren blätterteig und
schneiden den quadrate der selbst von
anderen vier mal der ist ein bisschen
dicker ihr könnt ihr auch dritten
blätterteig ruhig machen so ein bisschen
flach rollen aber ich finde das
eigentlich ganz okay gerade bei
herzhaften sachen darf auch ruhig ein
bisschen dicker sein dann einfach hier
rein drücken und dann befülle ich das
einfach mit der frischkäse masse und
klappe das noch mal so ein bisschen nach
innen und dann ist es auch schon fertig
ich gebe aber auch noch mal von der eier
milch mischung obendrauf damit hat wie
gesagt auch die optik stimmt aber
in dem fall könnte tier das sie sogar
weglassen ihr könnt übrigens auch nur
mit milch oder mit butter bestreichen
bei dekra teenie mangelhaft oder so kann
er sein sohn jetzt einfach rein und dann
verschließen
[Musik]
so die muffins kommen jetzt auch bei 190
grad ober und unterhitze in dem backofen
es ja schon vorgeheizt die ganze zeit
und da auch so lange bis sie goldbraun
werden ich gehe davon aus dass die paar
minuten länger brauchen und wir machen
weiter mit dem vierten und letzten
rezept
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt mein absoluter
lieblingskeksen ähnlich halloumi das ist
dieser clip käse schmeckt so lecker
leute ich habe jetzt hier einfach
nochmal blätterteig den ich in rechtecke
schneiden
also eher so ein bisschen länger
und dann kommt als basis einfach nur
paprika mark auf den blätterteig ich
habe vorab aber den halloumi schon in
streifen geschnitten und ohne fett in
der pfanne angebraten wirklich nur so
pro seite eine minute und dann bekommt
auch noch mal schön farbe und jetzt ihr
gesagt einfach paprika markt hier auf
dem blätterteig streichen dann halloumi
dazugeben und dann einfach nur noch die
seiten zusammenklappen
[Musik]
also ich werde jetzt hier nur noch mal
die eier milch mischung darüber geben
und dann finde ich passt sesam ganz gut
dazu oder auch schwarzkümmel und dann
kommt es auch in den backofen ich habe
ich bei carbon oder sesam und dann kommt
es in den backofen auch wieder bis es
goldbraun ist und dann haben die leute
vier leckereien in blätterteig und dann
bin ich ja mal gespannt was der hamburg
vor augen macht gleich
[Musik]
aber dazu gebracht hast gezaubert ich
habe vier verschiedene dinge aus
blätterteig gezaubert zweimal sie
zweimal herbede schokolade ja
keine ahnung käse und hast du ja harmlos
ist und halloumi von jacky bist du doof
ist
sehr dunkel aber
das
problem
alltag essen der hammer kirche
ja ich probiere mich durch die süßen
sachen einmal den kringel mit der
schuhcreme aber ganz also ich ganz
ehrlich ich finde das richtig geil weil
ich hinter halloumi passt richtig gut
mit der quali egger also diesen posten
also ich finde ich es mir das herz offen
ist das sieht heftig aus und auch der
heftig ja
ja genau also dieser rinder schinken
dann ist dann noch frischkäse drin
gewürze
lebensverhältnissen in
hamburg neugierig hier sind auch recht
groß ist ein großer haken muss ich sagen
einfach frischkäse wie ich weiß nicht
woher ich die süßen sachen obwohl sie
bisher kritisch wird es heftig wer also
man kann finde ich alles auch abgekühlt
essen es ist so wie mit hefeteig es
schmeckt natürlich war am besten ist
klar aber es ist kritisch
ich mache also dass das mal vor besitzt
jetzt gehen wir zum joussen all das sind
ja auch super lecker ist der dass man
sagt ich bin das richtig lecker vor
allem also der nicht dass man das so
aufgeräumt mit butter noch mal ein
gestrichener man merkt den unterschied
zu den kriminellen als mein fall gut
würde ich auch gern mal den anschnitt
zeigen guck mal das ist ganz anders
geschichte solcher und mindert das
kannst du chocolat
das gibt einfach immer das ist ja die
die schokocreme muss sagen die ist ja
allgemein noch nicht sehr süß also wenn
es jetzt noch mühsam möglich könnte noch
zum zucker drüberstreuen durch auch wenn
es cool finden also sollte nun
inspiration für euch sein es ist also
alles sehr einfach gehalten wirklich hab
ich doch sagen das war heftig ja das
kenne ich mich würde mal sagen um das
video nicht so sehr in die länge zu
strecken also mein gott das ist das
letzte video dieses jahr das ist
versetzte rezept video für dieses jahr
schon einmal stolpert die dass er die
sache
also ich mal sagen gebt uns doch einen
gefallen und schreib doch mal in die
kommentare welches video euch im juni am
besten gefallen habe das würde mich echt
wirklich sein aussehen und wenn ihr noch
nicht abonniert habe viele schauen auch
die videos ohne den abonnieren -button
geklickt zu haben dann wurde das jetz ma
und aktiviert die glocke für alle
benachrichtigungen weil nur so bekommt
ihr halt immer mit wenn wir mal was
hochladen also macht es gut in dem
bleibt gesund und rutscht gut ins neue
jahr und dann sind wir durch
[Musik]